il a fait entrer l'écologie avec
virulence dans la campagne
présidentielle en france nicolas hulot
est passé de son rôle d'observateur à
celui d'acteur politique
c'est l'une des personnalités marquantes
de l'année 2007 son portrait signé
jennifer alberte vous avez un quart
d'heure et ensuite on n'avait jamais vu
ça
à trois mois du premier tour des
présidentielles un animateur télé oblige
les candidats à l'élection suprême à
revoir en urgence leurs programmes
nicolas hulot convoque dix prétendants à
l'elysée pour qu'il fasse de l'écologie
un thème central de leur campagne
voilà le point d'orgue d'un parcours
politique entamée en août 2006 invité
aux universités d'été des verts nicolas
hulot affole à l'époque les compteurs
des sondages mais laisse planer le doute
mais moi j'ai pas très envie d'y aller
plus haut mais ce que je veux c'est que
cette campagne fasse pas l'impasse une
fois encore la sauva sur des enjeux qui
sont d'une telle échelle qui peuvent pas
faire l'objet d'une simple stratégie
électorale l'ancien conseiller de
jacques chirac
commence alors une valse hésitation j'y
vais j'y vais pas et finalement le 22
janvier 2007 il annonce qu'il n'entre
pas dans la course
la gorge serrée j'ai décidé de ne pas
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et de suspens donc mon
ingérence politique
la première raison la plus importante
revient à dire que j'ai choisi de faire
confiance à la parole et à l'engagement
des candidats car les colos star à une
autre stratégie en tête depuis un moment
il sillonne la france avec son pacte
écologique
cinq mesures phares parmi lesquelles
l'instauration d'une taxe carbone et la
création d'un poste de vice premier
ministre au développement durable
il fait pression sur les candidats
panique dans les états-majors l'écologie
politique devient la sphère de tous
nicolas hulot a arraché l'écologie à la
spécialisation politique des parties
qu'elles ont fait depuis 30 ans un usage
très politicien alliances électorales
débat politique parce qu'il est sorti
complètement des jeux partisans les jeux
tacticien une cité de la politique
pourquoi de l'écologie comme une cause
une fois élu l'autre nicolas doit tenir
son engagement il fait du ministre de
l'écologie le numéro deux du
gouvernement mais pas vice premier
ministre un grenelle de l'environnement
est organisée nicolas hulot est là deux
jours de négociations et en présence
d'al gore plusieurs mesures sont
énoncées dont la fameuse taxe carbone je
suis content que ce principe a été acté
la mise en oeuvre bercy va travailler
dessus et on va suivre ça
depuis nicolas hulot s'était plus
discret en politique
mais si les mesures du grenelle ne sont
pas mises en oeuvre il est fort à parier
que l'écologiste préféré des français
ressortira du bois